[Music]
even the cinematix go on everyone loves
that shot the Nutcracker
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
did you know Mortal Kombat's 11 comes
out this week of course you knew the
advertising has been absolutely
everywhere and it kept people on their
toes there's some damn good characters
so I thought we'd play for a little bit
and do disgusting things to other people
and probably get steve monetized but hey
it's worth it let the bloodbath begin
for each come on noob saibot I know what
I'm doing
throw this at your damn face I regret my
decision this isn't that fatal this is
our Hobbit but there's a little bit more
time okay in mortal combat alright just
let me get close okay I kind of get near
what you do now [__] Goro sitting
blocking his air thrown back there
doesn't look too good who's writing
history now anyway that's the problem
with history
Cassie look at that that's insanely good
Oh like your style girl GT Jax against
his own daughter
[Music]
that's damn nasty girl
nasty girl figure out mate give me a sec
you can't get in there slow out slowly
but surely there it is you can't get me
walk again look at I do fist well as
grotesque I love it
wooden move master just come up to the
cop this weapon in the corner come here
we owe after all that trying to get to
that weapon in the Congress thought damn
long but no it's not to be
gonna win this you're gonna win this
comeback is on place place this place
yeah I should have lost that no don't
lose it now don't lose it now don't
leave behind you [__] open your throat
this is just a typical date birthday in
Britain Wow that's profound ladies
always a guy damn lovely one for the
kids can't leave any help you fellow
well have fun for eternity yes oh the
Crypt is basically where we just go to
to unlock things
and it opens a new path so yeah here in
the crypts we spend all the coins that
we burned and unlock more consumables
more customizable
and just have fun with a with a big ass
the headless guy you my favorite monkey
to ever live for right I'm old Johnny
Cage versus young Johnny k'tau suitcases
ow vs. young Johnny Cage but I've got
moves to learn the blues punching the
Nats aah
oh he's hitting those right we're just
gonna check out do the punch in the nuts
back in a moment
nut punch city here we go whack yeah
nut fudge City hey you can jump you okay
you okay dude come back over [__] shots
oh I think I offended him
I'm okay how are your testicles testicle
drama be a really good bun name Jessica
drama that's how you win that is how you
win I love that move
oh poor sis look interactable this
interact with it come on come over yeah
damn SEC door how's your face do you
have like metal sports metal testicles
others others pain work on a robot
Oh even the cinematics go on God Vinnie
Jones shot the Nutcracker who that guy
in the background Sean I think we can
pick him up we have to get over yeah
okay got it down now not gonna lose okay
oh wow so fair his his answer
oh holy [__] did you see that the
agony
sorry I don't think I can get close to
this guy I'm the young one by the way
just in case you got completely lost
which is the women is not winning come
back to yourself stop hitting yourself
Jax this is the comeback of the year I
have a shotgun in the face it's all
right it's in Mortal Kombat down please
let me live
I'm so sorry did you come back don't
call it a comeback pretty for days yeah
now that's a finish up proud of that one
notch kick
all right we get enough from this bro
okay no one threatens my family yeah
nineties action films let's go in in the
menus I believe you can there it is you
can look at fatalities so let's look at
a few fatalities together
hashtag demonetised okay shotgun that's
a good start that's an impressive second
shot game of golf and he's heads come
out of his [__]
welcome to Mortal Kombat
Johnny Cage would you go
okay okay what the help watch for dinner
spaghetti or ramen man I'm really tall
oh my word he's adventurous it was
expecting that as a faint alligator
Johnny Cage rinse service right varaha
he's gonna do some a good of Baraka come
on Baraka watch it guys
whoa as a strong start I feel worried
that would be even better
okay okay what's next
did you hear the cough OH
lunch is next nicely done mother called
him Jackie Briggs what you got girl what
you got
oh that's not gonna end well for you
love Jackie whistles murdering her best
friend in the whole wide world sees
starlets taking out the blood up the
gasps oh you'll be right you've all
right see an eye doctor you'll be fine
fella
I retract my previous statement I don't
think that's fixable look at the fleshy
bits on the eyeball
oh yes
okay oh that was okay
okay it's just a spine oh and an eyeball
eyes for a second I thought eyeball was
like six foot like a massive eyeball
raised close to the camera
Wow Mortal Kombat 11 comes out this week
what do you think
[Music]